jessica is in Indiana Merry Christmas
Jessica how can I help
oh I am I
thank you at work cause a lot headphones
and I thought I was doing everything
right and apparently I'm not no I was
told to get credit cards do you build
your credit to buy a house so that's
what I did I got credit cards I got a
comm payment I just recently bought a
house so I didn't buy it obviously I got
a loan for it and I just don't know how
to start I heard of your I trying to be
before from the church I grew up in but
I never really you know paid attention
because I was younger and when I saw you
on podcast also see that this is and now
I'm like well crap I don't know where to
start because I screwed it all up oh
you're alright you're just normal
the only problem is normal is not
working right no it's like I pay a
little bit on a credit card and then I
use it again like you got sucked into
someone else's plan for making them rich
not you yeah and you know I thought I
was doing everything right my parents
didn't have credit cards they didn't
have the credit I never bought a house
so I was like I'm doing pretty good for
myself and I'm a mom of five and then I
heard the whole just get married well we
didn't get married because he has bad
credit and they're like if you get
married we'll face it off of his credit
as well and then you can't buy a home so
then I came home and I was like we're
doing it wrong we should get married
your credit doesn't matter so now we're
planning on getting married and
everything but it's like all those like
we've been together for six years that's
wonderful good okay so the point is if
we're going the wrong if you're driving
along the interstate and you realize
you're heading the wrong direction what
do you do you get off the exit you turn
left onto the bridge you turn left onto
the other exit ramp and you get up on
the ramp heading there
right direction and that's exactly what
you're doing well congratulations that's
awesome yeah okay and so now oh now
you've got a house you've got a husband
you have five kids are you about to have
a husband and we're you know and so
we're on our way let's just work these
baby steps and get you guys out of debt
so that you can become wealthy is that
okay I'm trying to do there you go so
you have credit card debt and you have a
car loan what else do you guys know a
mortgage yeah I mortgage and that's
that's really it like I hear everybody
else and I'm like okay well I'm not I
don't like I went to nursery I was
starting nursing school and since I
wasn't married obviously it was I ain't
got what are those loans or you don't
change it over yeah I got pell grant no
but so how much credit card n do you
have about ten thousand how much do you
owe on your car about ten thousand does
your husband-to-be have debt he had like
medical debt how much that he it's like
all together makes six thousand it's
like the four dollars that's just a bad
debt that's just bad credit
well his bad credit was from his he had
a car and he was pleading for the
military so he returned it and they
didn't want to take it back so they just
kept charging him but his mom co-signed
alright so it's on mom what she's paying
her back so yeah that would count that's
baby
yeah so she does she have the car or was
the car voluntarily reload finally he
just he drove it up there yeah you don't
have that you can't do that you can't
just drive it up there and leave it it's
not a rental car so he got his butt sued
is what happened okay so yeah you need
to find out what he owes on this stupid
car so his poor mama doesn't have to pay
it so what does he make a year and what
do you make a year I make about forty
every year and he makes about thirty
five years okay so when we're married we
had a $75,000 household income his new
wife has $20,000 in Daddy as 6,000 and
medical and an unknown amount on a bad
car deal right so what we're gonna do is
take all of these debts and we're gonna
list them smallest to largest we're
gonna pay minimum payments on everything
but the little one and we're going to
attack the smallest debt which is
probably one of those little medical
debts might be a small credit corner
with a vengeance when it's gone you
attack the next one down when that's
down when that's gone you attack the
next one down when that's gone you
attack the next one down one that's gone
you attack the next one down and so on
until they're all gone now when you
don't have any payments but the house
payment then then you move on to what we
call baby step three and you build an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses with a $75,000 household income
you should pay off $26,000 which is what
you guys have
not counting the car mess which we don't
know what it is in one year even with
five kids but that means you're living
on beans and rice rice and beans and
you're gonna quit going out to eat
you're not going on vacation you're
gonna clean up your childish mess and
when you get that done you'll deal with
this car deal then you got to get mama
out of this car deal just bless her
heart she got messed over by her son who
just walked away from a co-sign loan so
we got to go back straighten that mess
up and then we're debt-free then we
build an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses and you'll be right
on track
way to go welcome to the new tribe it's
a whole different way of living and when
you have no payments kiddo Wow
changes everything